um yo it's crazy because like I feel
like you know the drill scene and I mean
now that's really New York sound like
when we think about like the hot [__]
out of New York is really the drill [__]
but like um Brooklyn in particular
I feel like right around like 2018 2019
is like really when [__] like
really popped off like pop smoke Fabio
all that [__] little TJ yeah for you
guys
um well you guys always like big drill
fans
because you go I mean that's the
environment for me right that's over
here I go outside out here Joe it's like
you love him more when you was around it
so it's like when Pop smoke came out
like you know you had people from
Kenosha like me I went to school in
Canarsie I actually went to Oklahoma
yeah so we hung out with a Dusty volcano
there yeah so it's like the love like
that he had to the hood it just makes
you it makes them like they caught the
flaws yeah the floors on point like op
over there shout out to them got some
good food over there
felt like it was like it was cool you
know some parts man you have you guys
ever been to the part of Brooklyn
where they got the uh it's like the
Hasidic Jewish community
Eastern Parkway I don't know bro
I went over there with uh Ross there's a
lot there's a lot of Jewish communities
no it's the Hasidic Jewish community so
like they have like their own police
force and they have their own ambulances
and [__] it's [__] lit bro there's no
pokey right yeah so like if you got
stabbed over there
and the ambulance was there they'd be
like nah word that's so crazy
they're specific like because they have
their own like you know New York's a
wild Place bro so much culture it's
amazing I love it there yeah
when you guys go to La though or other
places do you realize like my life would
be a lot less stressful if I got the
[__] out of this place yo this is why we
like me personally I like getting out of
New York like it's such a it's a noise
it's like New York is reality you gotta
get on the subway bro it's just a lot of
a lot of nuggets every day you're
rubbing shoulders with people you don't
know oh no no we better start taking it
so big I promise you yeah but you gotta
walk down the [__] Street every like
not doing that that's how you put
yourself in predictions but that's why I
like other places because it's like I
get to walk like um like I get to take a
nice walk and just like get it leave
your front yard get in your car get some
[__] food now I'll probably do that
anywhere but New York yeah it's
definitely New York like I ain't gonna
lie I'm not even gonna see me in New
York I'm always on a v [__] don't know
my next move like you probably know how
to move in New York bro there is like I
do feel like um there's a lot of like
negative connotations with drill music
like we think of like a lot of the
violence that's come from some of the
beefs which obviously derives mostly
from the streets not necessarily the
music I do feel like you guys are moving
with a lot more of like a positive
energy if you're trying to change the
image yeah that's what we've been trying
a lot of people just deal with drugs
from some some negative [__] I was
[__] up hip hop hobo it's not that
it's just a style of music right it's
just a style of rapping it's a style of
Beats style of music and everybody's on
the drill [__] now I just think of like
going to let her yeah here you go
um
would you guys say you guys like are
making a conscious effort to kind of
change the narrative and just kind of do
it in your own way where it's not
necessarily so
revolving around the drama you know what
I mean I feel like that's why
people straight to us because it's like
we don't like tend to go towards the
distance like you know like all the bad
things about drilling right we just have
our own sound to it and that's what
people like you know I'm trying to say
it's like we're different we're not
trying to do what everybody else is
doing everybody else they rely on
addition because controversy brings
views yeah I feel like you guys are just
relying on good music real artists like
we really make real music rather Express
the talent than the politics that's
funny this [__] is bro
that's super dope